ich bin dein vater mama papa ärgert mich
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute geht es einem motiv torte zum
thema star wars hier also wer mich kennt
kann mich wahrscheinlich einschätzen ich
bin absolut kein star wars fan ich habe
auch noch nie einen film gesehen aber
der murat hat sich so sehr eine
standorte gewünscht und darth vader ist
einfach die einzige figur aus star wars
die ich kenne
das ist es nicht
das nehme ich dann für andere sachen für
prinzessin lillifee und so genau
star wars das ist das beste was es gibt
also ich weiß nur dass ich total der
hype das war auch beim ein großcousin
zum beispiel der lieb star wars über
alles aber ein start also er kann
eigentlich gar nicht alles daraus viel
lieber gesehen haben nicht mal ab 8 oder
9 auf jeden fall ist er ein star wars
fan und alle kinder sind star wars fan
und sammler sagt im hessischen jungs
führen
ok ja also wir starten jetzt gleich mit
dem tutorial aber für mich stellt sich
noch die frage
ich darf weder eigentlich gut oder böse
der doch weder ist alles böse der hat im
dritten teil glaube ich zwanzig oder
dreißig kinder zur strecke gebracht also
getötet sagt man jetzt auf einem kanal
kopf ihrer kinder zu ok hat nein er habe
die noch die freiheit schafft irgendwie
freitag gegangen auf die pfadfinder
freizeitpark oder hat sie einen bus in
den himmel gefahren rat ja auf jeden
fall ich merke schon das ist
wahrscheinlich die einzige film torte zu
recht den film niemals sehen werden
wieso nicht ich musste auch wieder gute
zeiten schlechte zeiten und schauen ich
guck lieber prinzessin statt
ich stelle jetzt direkt mit dem stapeln
der torte und zwar habe ich jetzt hier
bereits meine tortenböden vorgebacken da
habe ich die doppelte menge meine
saftigen schokoladenkuchen backen und
habe jeweils die 20 zentimeter form bin
uns also die gebag rahmen und einen teil
habe ich hier in dieser edelstahl
schlüssel gebacken
das habe ich dann oben da hab ich
einfach diese rundung für den kopf und
ich habe noch eine portion von einer
vollmilch garaus gemacht
jetzt fange ich direkt an ich hab die
böden hier muss jetzt erstmal
durchschneiden denn die fülle ich dann
einfach auch mit etwas garmisch
das habe ich hier bereits ein clipboard
mit 18 cm durchmesser und das bestreite
ich mit etwas ganache und setzt den
ersten boden drauf und jetzt fühle ich
die torte immer wieder mit garage und
setzt alle weiteren böden drauf
die torte sind zusammengesetzt und bevor
ich sie jetzt in form schneiden kann
muss ich sehr erstmal 30 minuten in den
kühlschrank stellen jetzt ist die torte
kalt und ich kann sie in form schneiden
und zuerst schreibe ich jetzt diese
ovale kopfform zurecht und danach dann
vorne eben die maske
die tochter habe ich jetzt erstmal groß
zurechtgeschnitten und auch ein bisschen
eingestrichen
als vorlage habe übrigens monats maske
einfach genommen und jetzt kommt die
tochter ist meinen kühlschrank so eine
halbe stunde und dann kann es noch mal
die feinheiten ausarbeiten
die gruppen stellen habe ich jetzt mit
garage ausgearbeitet und die feinheiten
mache ich jetzt mit modelliermasse bahn
mit schwarz dann möchte ich nämlich hier
gerade über die augen sowieso eine wurst
setzen damit einfach später der helm
schon auf sie auf liegt
ich schneide jetzt hier unten noch die
platte weg da kann ich nämlich später
den kopf einfach auf eine andere platte
setzen
die torte ist jetzt erstmal im
kühlschrank und ich bereit jetzt schon
mal den über zu kommen und zwar nehme
ich davon dann von und zwar habe ich
jetzt hier zwei päckchen schwarz und
zwei päckchen schokoladen fondant denn
dann schmeckt davon dann nämlich auch
richtig gut und ich mich jetzt einfach
schwarz mit schokolade und wenn es mir
nicht schwarz genug ist fertig einfach
mit passenden farben
jetzt müssen wir erstmal was kneten
jetzt nämlich denn von dort erst mal nur
die hälfte oder ein drittel ist es
ungefähr und bedecktes vorne erst mal
das gesicht und später mach ich dann den
helm drüber und am besten rolle von dort
immer auf etwas becken stärke aus
ich bin da jetzt vorne auch nur die
maske und schneidet auf den hinteren
teil gleich wieder weg weil er dann eben
den helm noch trüber kommen
ich bin dein vater
ich habe jetzt in vollbrand mit den
händen an gedrückt und die feinheiten
mache ich es einfach mit hilfe von ein
bisschen werkzeug also einem lineal im
marzipan messer und einfach meine
modelle werkzeug
ich habe jetzt die streifen wird es geht
hier zurecht geschnitten und am
einfachsten und am besten klebt man die
jetzt mit der wachs papier methode an
die hatte ich euch schon mal gezeigt und
so habe ich jetzt hier ein stück wachs
papier
das bestreite ich jetzt mit etwas pannen
und somit kokosfett dann klebt nämlich
gleich die dekoration gut an
jetzt kann ich die streifen da gut drauf
legen und mit lineal begradigen
jetzt bestreite ich die teile noch mit
etwas zucker kleber
jetzt kann ich mithilfe des papiers das
muster angegeben
und zum abschluss setzte ich hier oben
noch eine umrandung
ich habe die torte kurz in den
kühlschrank gestellt und bereits jetzt
einmal die tortenplatte vor
ich habe hier eine tortenplatte die ist
jetzt etwas größer als die torte die 30
zentimeter im durchmesser und dann rolle
ich jetzt etwas grau aus und bedeckte
damit den von damm klebe ich auf die
platte mit etwas zucker kleber
jetzt rede ich mit meinem modell ihr
werkzeug und meine marzipan messer noch
das muster vom todesstern von star wars
ein
und anschließend bei andere ich jetzt
den todesstern mit etwas pulver farbe in
schwarz weiß und silber
als er die tore drauf gesetzt und jetzt
möchte ich hier unten noch einen schönen
abschluss deswegen kommt noch ein dünnes
bams dran
jetzt bestreite ich die spitze der maske
noch mit etwas silber und formen aus
finnland noch ein paar schrauben und
habe auch die mit silber 1
ich habe jetzt ein ganz großes stück vom
bau ausgerollt und das wird jetzt der
helm vom darth vader
den vom land helm kann man mit etwas
küchenpapier verstärken und dann nach
dem trocknen wieder abnehmen
für die augen nämlich jetzt zwei stücke
von dort und drück sie flach und klebt
sie dann ein
das habe ich hier ein bisschen zucker
kleber mit etwas wasser verdünnt und
gestreichelt damit die augen damit die
glänzen
mit meiner freundin presse vor mich
jetzt einen langen dünnen strang
und den lege ich jetzt wie eine kontur
um die augen herum
jetzt tritt sich noch mit einem cutter
vorne ein muster ein
so sieht jetzt die fertige torte aus und
ich hab sie ein bisschen vereinfacht
also darf jeder hat ja so bisschen so
ein kantiges gesicht oder eine maske
sage ich jetzt mal aber ich hab's halt
so ein bisschen vereinfacht und ja das
ist die fertige torte ich kann es jetzt
leider nicht im video anschneiden denn
ich habe meinen bruder versprochen dass
er die torte bekommt ein großer star
wars fan wir mein bruder ist übrigens 30
wieso nicht hallo erkennt es schon immer
ich konnte ihn nicht leidend hallo ja ok
das hat er nicht so gemeint wer hat
eigentlich stehen darf weiter gespielt
also wäre ich der schauspieler da drin
zumal im prinzip kann ja weiß nicht wie
oft hat das nun aufgetauchte das kann
eben jemand anders gewesen sein
naja ich das ist wie ich so aber gewiss
nicht glauben das wird mit keiner
glauben der schauspieler für laufräder
geiles spiel war da
na ja also das war das ist meine filme
torte und falls ich sie nach machen
wollt gibt's das rezept auch sally
blog.de und ich hoffe dass nicht die
torte gefallen hat bitte gebt mir keinen
daumen runter wenn ihr keine star wars
bei das hat er das schon mal beinahe
ausgesagt
bei einer fußball trotte nein wieso ich
hatte also auf jeden fall ganz viel spaß
beim nachbacken und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder biss dann macht's
gut auf wie jobs war mache ich wieder
einem mädchen torte mit glitzer nein das
reicht so verhindern müssen
ich bin dein vater auf